hey everyone welcome back to another
video on the react series
in this video we will learn about the
two fundamental concepts of react
state and props but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to us already hit
the subscribe button
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
first we will understand how react state
works and then
we will dive into props so without
further ado let's begin
typically a state is an object that
stores the values of
properties belonging to a component now
these values can change over a period of
time
either via user interactions or network
changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality every time
the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser
the state is initialized in the
constructor a state can also store
multiple properties a method called set
state is used to
update the value of the state object now
this function performs a shallow merge
on the new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props
and although props and state dictate and
control the behavior of a component they
have significant differences
so let's go ahead and draw a comparison
between the two firstly props in a
component are used to pass
data and event handlers to its children
while state on the other hand is used to
store the data that has to be rendered
on the web page
props are immutable once said by the
parent they cannot be changed
state holds volatile data and can be
changed over time
props can be used in functional and
class components while state is
restricted to class components
props are set by the parent component
while a state is generally updated by
event handlers
now that we've learned all about state
let's go ahead and build an application
to see the working
of state all right so in my code editor
that is vs code i've created my
application say state
and here in my source folder i have my
app.js file
now here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary
code that i'm not going to be using also
i suggest you go through the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started with
creating your first application so let's
create our class component
say class app extends
react top component and inside i have a
render method
that returns an html tag let's display a
message
welcome let's follow the jsx conventions
and enclose all the html tags within the
div tag
so i say div class name
equals app we also have to import the
app.css file
import app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome
now let's beautify our code to do that
let's add some styling
so here in my app.js class component i
say
styles equals and i say
font style and i set it to say
bold and i say color
say teal and here in my h1 tag
i say style equals this
dot styles so let me save it and if you
look at the browser now
we have welcome in teal and it's bold
now let's go ahead and create
a class component to understand state so
first i create a folder
and i call it components and inside this
folder i create
a class component and i call it new comp
dot js and i use the snippet rce
to create the class component to give
you an insight into what we're doing
today
we'll display a message asking the user
to subscribe to simply learn
once the user clicks on the subscribe
button we instruct them to click on the
bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state
and as mentioned earlier we initialize
the state object
in a constructor so let's use the
snippet r
const to create a constructor now in the
state object
we initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this dot state dot
message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component
so i'll get rid of export here and here
i say
import new comp from components
and newcom and let's define it here
and say new so we save it and look at
the browser
it says subscribe to sunclone all right
again to make our code look more
presentable let's add in styles
so i'll just copy the same styles that
i've added here
and i'll paste them here and instead of
bold i make it italic
and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style and initialize it to distort
styles
so let me save it and now if you look at
the browser it's
in italic and it's in purple okay so
moving ahead
let's create a button that reads
subscribe and once the user clicks on it
the button should read subscribed and
the message displayed above
should instruct the user to click on the
bell icon to do that
let's first create a button the message
that i want the button to read is
subscribe
however this message gets changed once
the user clicks on the button
so instead of explicitly mentioning
subscribe here
i create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method
i say this dot state dot
sub so let's save it and if you look at
the browser now
you have a button which displays a
message subscribe now once the user
clicks on the button
the message displayed should change to
click on the bell icon to never miss an
update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method button change
okay so this method should update the
state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a set
state method
now a state can be updated in response
to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done
using the set state method now this is
the general syntax used by the method
we'll have a look at this further in the
demo
now the set state method conventionally
encues all the updates made to the
component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state
now let's go back to our code editor and
look at the working of this method
now here i defined the arrow function
button
change if you are not familiar with
arrow functions i suggest you read up on
them
and this is the general syntax and here
i say
this dot set state and inside
i change my message to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update and my sub
value changes to subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser
when we click on the subscribe button
the message changes to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update
so moving ahead let's use a bell icon so
that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message
appears on the screen so for that i have
two images
i have bell a and bell b so i drag and
drop both the images
in my components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from bell a dot png
and again i say import bell b from
bell b dot png
all right let me save it to display the
image on the screen we make use of the
image tag
now this tag has two attributes one is
the source attribute that specifies the
url
and the other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image
so here in my component i say i make use
of a paragraph tag
that will help display the image in the
next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked
i have to define a property and pass the
event handler click
that will update the image so here
before
specifying the source let's go back to
our state
and define another property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it and
here
in my image tag i say source equals
this dot state dot image url
and then we have the alt tag and i do
not want to display any message
so i leave it as it is now let's save it
and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell
so back in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this
and now if you look at the browser we
have a smaller icon
so once the user clicks on this image
the emit changes
and the message displayed here gets
updated to do that we'll have to define
an event
so let's go back to our vs code and here
in my image tag
let's say on click i define a method say
this
dot image change and now
we define this method here i see
image change i make use of an arrow
function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image
so i say image url is now set to
bell b and the message is updated
to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser
we see the image and once clicked on it
the image gets updated
and the message changes so finally let
me refresh the browser once and show the
full execution
let me refresh following the
instructions let's click
on the subscribe button and now it says
hit the bell icon
and once i do that the image updates and
the message
changes props short for properties allow
the user to pass
arguments or data to components a parent
component can pass
additional information to its children
using props
properties help make components more
dynamic
props are passed to components in the
way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed
one thing to remember is that props are
sent by the parent to the children
components
hence the children components cannot
make any changes to these props
now that we've learnt about props in
brief let's go ahead and create our
application using props
if you're new to this tutorial i suggest
you go to the react
installation and react components video
on our channel
so back in my code editor that is vs
code i've opened a folder called
react props and now i'm going to create
a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component
i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
all right now let me get rid of export
here
and import it in my app.js main
component
here i say import
class props all right now we define the
class component in our render method
let's say
all right now if we go back to the
browser you see hello learners welcome
to simply learning
now let's say we want to individually
welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props
now let's see how to do that now we pass
the name as a property
from the main component that is app.js
to the child component
and render this onto the browser so
let's do that
so here while i'm defining my child
component
i say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners i say i use the
keyword this
dot props dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner two and
learner three
so i again say class props name
equals learner to
all right so if we save and look at the
browser
we'll have all the three learners
displayed on the browser
we can also pass multiple props to the
child component
now say for example we want to welcome
the student from a particular place
so we say welcome learner1 from place x
so i can here define another property
say
place and say
place similarly i can do it
for the rest too say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component
and here say hello learner1
from this dot props
dot place let me save it
and if you look at the browser now we
have hello learner 1 from place x
place y and place z we can also display
whatever we want between the opening and
closing tags when invoking a component
now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you
how it's done with an example here let's
split the self and closing tag
into an opening and a closing tag and in
between them
let me display a message within the
paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my h1
tag let me use a paragraph tag
and here let's use the reserved keyword
this dot props top children
so let's save it and now if you look at
the browser
you can here see the message displayed
child component
so prop stop children can be used when
components do not know about their
children ahead of time this is commonly
seen in components like sidebar and
dialog
that represent generic boxes so let's go
ahead
and create a button tag and check again
so here i'll split it and add
a button tag and say click
and let's check our browser here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props
for class components similarly we can
use it for functional components
so let's go ahead and create a
functional component let me call it
i say import react from
react and then i say function
function props and here i return
an h3 tag
[Music]
i'll say this is functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag saying
hello learner so let me save this
and let's export it export
default function
props and import it
in our app.js again import
function prop from
function problem and here
in our render method let's define it
let me call function prop
name let me give learner 4
and place
place say a let me
close it and back in our functional
component
instead of learner i say
props dot name let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says
props is not defined so let's go back to
our code editor
and pass props here to our functional
component
also let me define hello props dot name
from props dot place
[Music]
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go
we get the output as expected with this
we've reached the end of the video
in our upcoming video you'll learn more
about props and how they're used
so watch out for that until then keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here